なんやねんんんんんん
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんアイスクリーム好きですか？
なんか僕冬の方がむしろアイスクリーム食べたくなちゃうんですよ
外は寒いじゃないですか
けど家はあったかい
こたつあったかい
お風呂あったかい
暑い中食うアイスクリームが最高においしいんですわ
そこで皆さん
世の中には色んなアイスクリームがあると思うんですけども
そのアイスクリームの頂点に君臨するものが何か
そう
no no no no
ﾊｰｹﾞﾝﾀﾞｯﾄｩ
そう
世の中のアイスクリームの頂点に君臨するもの
それこそがハーゲンダッツ
そんなハーゲンダッツを
(ﾊﾞﾝ)
ﾜｧ！
やべえ　2Lのハーゲンダッツ約4000円くらいです
おぉ！
すごいすごい
ほーうわーいやーうわぁぁぁ
ちょっとでかいかなぁぁぁぁ
業務用2Lでございます
パッと見ペヤング焼きそばなんですけども
中身はちゃんと高級アイス
ハーゲンダッツ
２ℓです☆
はっ！はっ！すごいすごいすごい！
おっぱいだ！
おっ、おっぱいだおっぱいだ！
見えますかほらなんかちょっとおっぱいぽくないっすかほら！
おっぱいだ、おっぱi
何を隠そうが大好きなアイスクリームの味は
そしてアイスクリームの頂点に君臨するハーゲンダッツ
僕今日お腹ペコペコなんで
この状況なら多分2Lのアイスクリームましてや
ハーゲンダッツですよ
2Lのハーゲンダッツだったら多分あの
全く嫌な思いせず食べれるんじゃないかなと思いまして
今回2Lのハーゲンダッツを1人で食ってみようと思います
ｲﾀﾀﾞｷﾏｽ！
うわ、やわらか
いただきます
はっ！うまい！
ちゃんとハーゲンダッツだ！！
うめぇうめぇぞ！
手が震えちまうよ
(ｶｯｶｯｶｯ)
ｺﾞﾎｯｺﾞﾎｯ
あーうまい
本当に普通にいけます多分
どんどん食っていきます
んーｷｬｯｷｬｯ
すいません早く食べます
ほ～
うまいな
あのアイスクリームって分かります？
周りが美味しいじゃないですか
なんか周りから溶けちゃうからほらついつい周りばっかり食べちゃう
やばい！
まじで本当に幸せだな
はい、今のところ全然飽きてないし
なんか幸せっす
この幸せがあとどれだけ続くのかなぁ
ﾊﾊｯ
えまじでいける気がするこれ
本当にまじうまいもん
ちょっと体が寒くなってきました
体温が下がってんのかな
ﾊﾊｯ
あー頭痛い
頭痛いよ
やばいお腹痛い
お腹痛いお腹痛い、お腹痛い！
あー！
アーッ！
ちょっとやっぱり
すいません、まだもうちょい食べれそうなんですけど
ちょっと助っ人を呼んで
とりあえずなんとか食べていこうと思います
吹きます
♪～
まさき：えっ？
まさき：ええ！？ハ、ハーゲンダッツ！？
え、まじで！？
はじめ：いやいやだからあの、
お、美味しいんすよ
2Lでも美味しければいけるんじゃないかと思ったんですけど
ちょっと無理だったんで
まさき：いや、ハーゲンダッツならいけるでしょ！
はじめ：いやいやそう思ってたんよ
まさき：ハーゲンダッツだよ？
はじめ：いやまだ美味しいんだよ美味しいのは分かるんだけど
もうちょっと舌が限界なんで
とりあえず食べよう！
まさき：食べよう
はじめ：2L食べよう
というわけでとりあえず何としてでも
2Lは食べます
まさき：うわ～うめぇ
はじめ：いや美味しいのは承知なんだけどね
まさき：美味しいんだよ
はじめ：美味しい美味しい
はじめ：いやちょそういう・・そういうのはそういうのは
まさき：そういう企画じゃない？
はじめ：え、でもほらもうあと俺たちほらだって
ねえ
はじめ：すごいんすよ。なんか、胸にくるよね
なんか・・・な、なんだ、あの・・・
感動じゃねえわ！
(くしゃみ)
まさき：絶対寒いからだよ
はじめ：今素直につらかったよね
まさき：うん
はじめ：いやけどもう本当にラスト、ラストスパートです
おっ！んん！
おおっ！
おおっ↑！
はじめ：はぁはい！　あ・・！
まさき：あとこれこれ
はじめ：ラストいきます！
う゛～～ん！
（エンディング）